OF MAR-A-LAGO.
>> ALL RIGHT, KAITLAN, STAY WITH
US.
I WANT TO BRING IN FORMER
REPUBLICAN OHIO GOVERNOR JOHN
KASICH.
GOVERNOR KASICH, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THOSE FORCEFUL REMARKS
FROM THE PRESIDENT AIMED
SQUARELY AT MEMBERS OF YOUR
PARTY?
>> WELL, I THINK IT'S -- YOU
KNOW, ISSUES ARE FAIR GAME,
PAMELA.
YOU KNOW, HE'S OUT THERE TALKING
ABOUT GUNS AND HE'S TALKING
ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
I THINK IT'S ALL LEGITIMATE.
AND THE RHETORIC IS GOING TO GET
HOTTER AND HOTTER AS WE GET
CLOSER TO THE ELECTION.
BUT I'M TOLD THAT HE WAS
REPORTED AS COMPARING THESE MAGA
REPUBLICANS TO I THINK CALLING
THEM LIKE SEMI-FASCIST.
OKAY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WANT OUT OF
JOE BIDEN.
THAT'S THE KIND OF STUFF YOU
HEAR OUT OF DONALD TRUMP.
SO YOU CAN BE HEATED BUT BE
CAREFUL YOU DON'T GO OVER THE
LINE BECAUSE IF YOU'RE BATTLING
FOR THE SOUL OF THE COUNTRY, IF
I'M BATTLING FOR THE SOUL OF THE
COUNTRY, I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET MOST PEOPLE
TOGETHER, NOT PUSHING MOST
PEOPLE APART.
BUT WE'RE IN A POLITICAL SEASON
RIGHT NOW.
IT INVOLVES FUND-RAISING AND
THAT KIND OF HIGH RHETORIC
PROBABLY RAISES SOME MONEY, AND
IT'S OKAY FOR THEM TO TALK ABOUT
ISSUES.
I WOULD RATHER THEM BE TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUES OF GUNS AND
CRIME THAN ALL THE STUFF THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS.
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
>> CERTAINLY, KAITLAN, THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN RAMPING UP
HIS RHETORIC.
AS YOU SAID, TODAY HAS BEEN ONE
OF HIS MOST FORCEFUL SPEECHES TO
DATE.
WHY ARE WE HEARING THIS MESSAGE
FROM THE PRESIDENT FOCUSING ON
REPUBLICANS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
RIGHT NOW?
>> I THINK WITH THE FBI, IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE ATTACKS, THE
SPIKE YOU HAVE SEEN IN THE
THREATS AGAINST THE FBI AND
THESE RANK AND FILE MEMBERS
WHICH AS PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
EARLIER TODAY, THEY WERE JUST
DOING THEIR JOB WHEN THEY
EXECUTED THAT SEARCH WARRANT ON
MAR-A-LAGO.
THE OTHER HAND IS THAT WE'RE TEN
WEEKS OUT FROM THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS SO THIS OVERARCHING
MESSAGE YOU'RE SEEING WHERE
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS EMPHASIZING
THIS CONTRAST BETWEEN DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS, THAT'S THE
POINT OF THAT.
THAT AND WHY HE WAS IN
PENNSYLVANIA TODAY.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT HIS
STRATEGY TO REDUCE CRIME IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HE ALSO TOOK PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO DRAW THAT
CONTRAST BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
AND PUSHING FOR, OF COURSE,
DEMOCRATS IN THAT STATE SINCE
THEY ARE ELECTING A NEW
GOVERNOR, PICKING A NEW SENATOR.
THE GOVERNOR IS GOING TO PICK A
SECRETARY OF STATE WHO IS CHIEF
AND CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S
ELECTIONS AND HOW THOSE ARE
CARRIED OUT.
BASICALLY MAKING THE ARGUMENT
THAT THERE IS A LOT ON THE LINE.
AND PENNSYLVANIA IS GETTING A
LOT OF ATTENTION FROM THIS
PRESIDENT, SPECIFICALLY RIGHT
NOW.
HE'S GOING TO VISIT THERE TWO
MORE TIMES WITHIN THE NEXT WEEK
ALONE.
TRUMP IS GOING TO BE THERE
HOLDING HIS OWN RALLY ON
SATURDAY.
AND I SHOULD NOTE IN THE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH ON THURSDAY,
IT IS GOING TO HARKEN BACK TO
THAT MESSAGE YOU OFTEN HEARD
FROM HIM ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
ABOUT DEMOCRACY BEING UNDER
ATTACK.
>> GOVERNOR KASICH, REPUBLICANS
HAVE TRIED TO -- GO AHEAD.
>> YEAH.
I WAS GOING TO SAY, LOOK, THERE
IS NO EXCUSE AND NO REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO STAND UP AND DEFUND
THE FBI.
AND THAT'S WRONG TO ATTACK THIS
KIND OF AN INSTITUTION.
WE HAVE TO SEE HOW THIS ALL
PLAYS OUT.
BUT IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE JOE
BIDEN TRYING TO TURN THE TABLES
AND SAY, I'M NOT FOR DEFUNDING
THE POLICE, WHEN AS YOU KNOW,
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BEEN
PLAYING CATCH-UP BECAUSE OF THE
SENSE OF SOME PEOPLE IN THE
PARTY, EXTREMISTS JUST LIKE YOU
HAVE IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
EXTREMISTS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY SAYING WE SHOULD DEFUND
THE POLICE.
WE'RE NOT DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
IN FACT WE'RE REFUNDING THEM
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE